What is up, guys? I'm going to be
showing you how to make loads of money
overnight. So, what we're going to be
doing, we're going to be buying items
overnight and then in the morning, we
will sell them.
So, I'm going to check the airoon
and then sell it.
Okay, so four coins. So these basically
instant sell for five coins.
So you're going to buy 400k of them. And
then you're going to do the same with
water runes.
Buy them for four coins. I think it's
like 25k over 4 hours, something like
that.
So basically, this is going to be about
400k right here.
Earth rune. Okay. I was trying to
remember what the other room was. So,
100k of these.
And then another item
that I flip overnight are cannonballs.
So, cannon ball.
So, you want to buy them for 184. And I
always just put in an offer for 20k just
to see how many buy because I think it's
like uh I want to say 6,000 every four
hours. Not sure. for another item that I
like to buy. It's kind of high price
right now, so I'm kind of sketched to do
this, but I'm going to go ahead and do
it anyways. So, I'm going to put in an
offer for 2091K and it's selling for
2245. Normally, it sells for 21 like 30.
So, I can buy it for just under 2 mil
and make 100 mil. So, I'm kind of
scared. I mean, I can make 100K. I'm
kind of scared that this is
going to buy for that and then not sell
for that in the morning. And then
another item that I like to do a lot is
our robe skirts. They're also raising a
lot, so this might not work either, but
we'll go ahead and put in an offer for
let's try 10 uh 105k.
We'll go ahead and try to buy like eight
of those actually. Yeah, eight of those.
Let me try to think of one more item
before we go. Sometimes the rock plate
skirt works really well. Sometimes iron
knives work. Kind of depends. Let's just
actually No, no, no. I just remember
Gothic's cloaks is what I do.
So, a few items I do. I do Gothic's
cloak sometimes. I like to do the tribal
masks because those flip really well.
So, I mean, there's quite a few items
you can do. So, I'm just going to price
like this myself right now because I'm
not sure what it sells for. I bet the
market's pretty high right now.
So, that'll Yeah, it's really high right
now. So, the difference between these is
about 10K. So, we'll go ahead and put in
an offer for
we'll go 29
uh 550. Actually, we'll just do an even
30K and drop it down one. And we'll buy
we'll just try to buy 20 of them. See
what happens. So, now in the morning, I
will come back and see what sold. And
then I will try to sell them and tell
you guys how long they took to sell. So,
I'll see you in the morning. I am
narrating this part just so you guys
know. So this is when I checked this
morning. Let me put in my pin. So
basically this was about five hours
because I only got about five hours of
sleep because I did this late and had to
wake up early for work. So nothing sold
except that. So I will come back after
work and check what has sold. All right
guys, it is now after work. So it's been
about 8 hours. Let's go ahead and see if
anything sold. Okay, so we have do have
some stuff selling. Put my pin in. All
right, it looks like I am lagging out.
So,
uh, I'll be right back. All right, let's
try that again.
Okay, so we sold or we bought 14,000 air
runes, 20,000 water runes.
Oh my goodness, I'm lagging.
Um, we're supposed to get new internet
soon, but I think I will be gone to
college. So, these didn't sell. So,
normally I buy these for 185, but I have
bought them for 184 in the past. So, I
think the problem there was when I
bought them for 184 instead of 185. My
goodness, I am lagging. This didn't buy,
which I'm okay with cuz I'm pretty sure
the price is kind of sketchy right now.
So, yeah, it's pretty high. So, it
didn't drop, but I was right it would
drop. Okay, so we did buy all these.
Let's go ahead and see what the ARMS
rope shirts are selling for. So, we can
make 40k profit on each of these about.
So, that'll be good. So, a lot of these
bought for 30K. Just under 30K. Let's
check what those are selling for.
Okay. So, we can make about 6K on each
of those. So, that'll be very nice.
So, we'll put these in for 36K even.
We will put these in for
1090 even.
And then we'll put these in for five
coins. We'll put these in for five
coins. We will put these in for five
coins. And finally, we will put these in
for five coins. So, I will Oh, look.
Those already sold. So, I will come back
when these sell and show you guys what
happened. This is literally maybe about
30 seconds later. So, keep in mind all
this stuff should sell fast. So, this
isn't like going to take more than
probably I don't know. I'd say the
longest one is probably going to be the
Gothic's cloaks. But, I will come back
when everything sells. And if the Gothic
cloaks don't sell right away, then I'll
show you guys that later. But, I will be
right back. See, these are already
selling. So, be right back, guys. So, it
has been about five to maybe 8 minutes,
I think, and almost all the skirts have
sold.
Two of the Guth explosives have sold.
All the runes sold pretty much right
away. And these water runes aren't
selling. So, I'm hoping all this sells.
So, I'll come back in another hopefully
5 minutes, maybe 10 minutes. So, it's
been literally 3 minutes. This sold
almost instantly when I said I'll be
right back. But the other stuff is not
sell. Oh, actually, one of these sold. I
didn't even catch that. So, one of those
sold. But anyways, I'm going to do the
math on what we will make when all these
sell and then I will be back. Okay, so
this is all the stuff that we bought and
I already looked at what they will all
sell for. So including the Gothics
cloaks and the water runes. So we made
102K on the Gothics cloaks. We made 280k
on the Arams ropes cards, 1,898 on the
earth runes, 15,918 on the fire runes,
20,043 on the water runes, and 14,13 on
the air runes for a grand total of 433k
889.
So if we added in the fact that if I
bought the cannons for 185 and then sold
them for 192, I would have made an
average of 82k, which is normally what I
make. And then if I sold the smoke
battle staffer in the morning for 100k
profit, which is normally what happens,
then that would bring me up to an easy
600k, even more. So you can make
anywhere between 433k and 600k plus
doing this method. I hope this video
helps you guys and I hope you guys make
lots of money overnight or when you're
at work. And thanks for watching, guys.
Stay tuned for my next video.